I'm Russell Wilson quarterback the
Seattle Seahawks and we're playing start
[ __ ] cut I'm gonna go to start I'm
gonna Remember the Titans all my
favorite movies of all time
I'm gonna go to bench I'm gonna go Rudy
I'm gonna go I'm gonna go to cut I'm
gonna go Friday Night Lights because you
can't beat the other two Fannett fantasy
series I'm definitely going Game of
Thrones I'm starting for sure I love
Khaleesi
the next one I'm gonna go I'm gonna go
to [ __ ] I'm a bench Harry Potter and
then Lord of the Rings I'm gonna cut
it's a little older goats Tiger Woods
Serena Williams Tom Brady I'm not
cutting anybody you can't kind of go
yeah we all start everybody vans oh man
I'm definitely starting I'm definitely
starting voice to man for sure Motown
Philly back again that's gonna be the
one
I mean we're gonna we're gonna we're
gonna we're gonna bench BTS and we're
gonna cut in sync you know there's their
cut anyway right now
Super Bowl party food I'm definitely
going a seven-layer dip I'm starting
with that Pizza going I'm gonna bench it
and then I'm gonna cut I'm gonna cut the
wing well I love something lighter dip
those seven layers
oh man I kind of dancing but I'm
definitely going to moonwalk just
because Michael Jackson walking is the
best and shout-out to Sierra two and
then I'm gonna bench the Carlton and I'm
gonna cut I'm gonna cut the Doug but you
know people walks when we do this you
know you know that whole thing I'm
Russell Wilson and that was start bench
cut